so as we've discovered Mangal is the son
of a [ __ ] Mangal is a big pile of poo
Mangal sucks donkey dong
then heard a moaning someone's moaning
out there that's not good
what kind of weirdo live it whenever I
walk into a place especially one with
bathrooms I immediately go and check all
the toilets [ __ ] Oh God
I heard the slippy slappy sounds of
footsteps
Oh everything's great
choo-choo here comes all day long oh my
god hey happy happy happy happy happy
day this bears bears bears bears bears
bears bears bad luck me Mandy
bad bad bad boys most bears never ever
ever women
No oh god oh god oh god [ __ ] me oh come
on what what happened oh god damn it
I've come to realize that I become
monster oh God
oh oh oh am i dead
am i dead Oh am i dead oh my dad oh oh
oh oh no no no no no I what this is
baloney
this is malarkey this is asinine
this is impossible [ __ ] it's gotta go
on forever I'm always gonna be the king
of five nights at freddys huh
Oh
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like let me know if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more on a daily basis please subscribe
today or if you're already subscribed
share this video with a friend thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
the next video bye bye